turning to the pandemic a new strain of
the coronavirus in the u.s
could be partially resistant to existing
vaccines two people in south carolina
tested positive for the variant which
was first discovered in south africa
that makes 29 states where new strains
of the virus
have been detected the vaccines do
appear to work on the variants
initially found in the uk and brazil
mola lenghi joins us from a vaccine site
in new york mueller good morning
good morning anthony sites like this one
vaccination sites have recently reopened
after the federal government started
increasing the number of doses it sends
to states but
supply is still a concern and the
rollout is still going slower
than many people had hoped the need to
vaccinate as many americans as possible
is more urgent than ever as the variant
of covid19
first identified in south africa has now
been found in the u.s
it was detected in two people from south
carolina from separate parts of the
state
there is no known travel history and
there is no known connection between the
two cases
with highly contagious variants reported
in at least 28 other states
officials should think carefully before
relaxing covid restrictions
warns dr ashisha by mid to late march
these variants could be quite
common and dominant in the united states
we could see huge spikes in cases large
spikes in hospitalizations and deaths
and the slow vaccination process could
make things
worse the longer we take the more there
are going to be opportunities for
variants
uh that could become even more dangerous
more lethal more contagious
or just escape our vaccines altogether
so far the currently authorized slate of
vaccines remain effective on all known
strains
though preliminary findings suggest they
may offer reduced protection against the
variant originally detected in south
africa
but the work to understand these new
strains and their interactions with
existing treatments
is well underway earlier this month we
visited dr dan berut
the director of the center for virology
and vaccine research in boston
if the vaccine is not as effective on
the new variant
what then well fortunately the first two
vaccines that we have here in the united
states
have proven to be highly highly
effective in the worst case scenario
then vaccines might need to be updated
and companies are already working on
those updates both
moderna and pfizer are developing
booster shots
for the south african variant of the
virus
tony mola thank you very much